[Music]
Oh
[Music]
live from Guardian con you got some cool
people in the building checking things
out right quick the line is a bit crazy
we've got some exciting pong action
going on right now
laughs Cece already know what it is
Florida beautiful Orlando you're about
to get it on who is this outfit is lit I
like the outfit bro outfits live I'm
about that always got the cwiebe right
that's nice that's nice I'm diggin it
I'm digging this itself
laughs for Guardian color all right so
what if you got your badge
what if you got your badge
all right mommy talk about let's go
all right where are the festivities all
right okay we checking it out y'all
alive from guardia cow on the way
bounces that we got to find him out he
overslept this morning
lady Desiree and the fielding saloon all
right so this isn't like the arcade
section going on checking it out
arcade games in the field at Guardian
cons doing it quite well
oh we got Ninja Turtles hey Lydia here
today we got some ninja turtles pinball
going on - turns pinball in the game
right see what it is
laughs he's gonna give me that ILP feel
gaming is going down
and I we believe we got a mortal kombat
going over there oh we got some
so
a lot of variety of games check it out
we got our Bordelaise people in the
building
we could shimmy
[Music]
this is classic left for dead all right
that's what's up
right my man playing with the mask the
optimal experience what's going on
family though
though the gaming is in the building at
Guardian comm you're a gamer even if you
don't like destiny it's in the building
what is that skill a cool
[Music]
okay looks interesting
we gotta figure out what that is I gotta
figure out what that NBA Showtime in the
building remember this
every a Showtime class
la revolucion
interesting
looks pretty cool
all the sega classic but i know about
this that afterburner that joystick
action which i know about this
to say it was rolling out here
a lot of gage a lot of good vintage miss
packed me we got we got Orange County in
the building Orange County getting at
with factory that's there we go the
competition is fierce
[Laughter]
there we go vintage tree fightin let's
go that Sean Lee
overdrive this one that's pretty cool
you could sell as old
tell that
[ __ ] back to that
Lucent world
oh here we go
which I know about that Daytona which I
know about that Daytona year
sorry
crazy
with
[Music]
so
night food 43
okay
kind of build it up great cigarette
I'm playing though I go play on a go
south of oh boy jingle will Twitter this
means
[Music]
lots of games inhale
lives here
I don't know what this game is
I'm trying to figure it out 2011 forget
stuff it is hot and heavy
I gotta see more this they getting it in
2011 Fiesta baby I don't know what this
game is but I get it in now making it
exciting
[Music]
I clearly must step to the beat
[Music]
business
eleven we have
now here it is let the turtle super
sister what's this
I don't work use the on Nintendo you
down you just want to say good job
yeah we got to blow the cartridge for
this to work I guess
Cheryl did attend Oh super system
we're gonna try to get in this car on
y'all we will try to get in this car and
see what's going on Wow
Sekar edition
service status
nice rest
[Applause]
all right we're gonna get in his car
we're gonna link back up and see what's
going on as I saw before does good
brother get in his car knee off about to
see what's going on we are in Guardian
Conn ladies and gentlemen
we are in the building we're gonna check
it out see who we can bump into Guardian
Con is live it is lit gaming does y'all
good you heard it here first
Oh t-rex in the building okay
Audio Cosway
see Rex in the building slow
[Music]
second
[Music]
a lot going on y'all it is it is punches
in the building just say yeah I think if
got a no one sits in the but old section
me now right here oh we live
but you see the building of this a young
know sufficient
oh that's an artwork of my head okay the
lumina
looking efficient
[Music]
the Krauts help us down
serious artwork serious I'm gonna be
broke
Akari see I'm Lee broke
start getting it
James so much going on we got panels
live or stage I don't know who was -
that is attachment
you're working that we gonna let him
work we're gonna let him water look at
Ashworth
- no that's my man right there he gets
it in he is hilarious great content
creator lines are crazy for something
trying to figure out what the allowances
about it's crazy I'm gonna loop back
around though it is insane
yeah
those borders
yes please videos
[Music]
what just getting there took this game
was there it's obvious a destiny Phyllis
what happened that's what you do to the
community
yeah galvanize salute is lit out but all
in positivity st. jude's foundation all
that does stuff they will move around a
little bit we're gonna move a shake
still haven't see any boxes the last
word still looking for now
[Music]
it's crazy
we Arsenal aiming on a CT
look at the look at the spacious going
on
you got she's destiny action orgies and
official setups are we late
there
so we always Annabelle degrees
[Music]
our peers
efficient
that's your game and we got some is Lego
is that a risk I gotta see the risk Iran
the homie wow that's crazy
we got a Lego risk or under that serious
audio card 2019 wheel it out here yeah
[Music]
Orlando Florida was oh we got
Borderlands in the building I could sue
moms look crazy for that to a good boy
Lance definitely showing it coexists
sharp gearbox to other Bungie
Alliance is crazy for this - it
not really crazy oh this is Raptor when
I go from it's boiling it's real of a
series to go head-to-head to September
[Music]
oh we got the Destiny shadow key in the
building I gotta get that artwork so
yeah I can see what's going on
[Music]
gotta get that all work destiny -
shouting Pete September
play cross name Julie Harris is back
souls on the moon it's late
Oh
it is insane Xiao de st. chosen a
building if showing its out at all the
legendary the legendary my name is Bai
for the building my lingo it's the law
section rated this for the Lord goos
we've got myelin games in the building
it's working that so up dammit route in
the building
well this the law section I'm in the
right section like this the good spot
the prince is laid to
gambits rat representing all right okay
Milan in the building salute be working
circuit or by Dasia okay
LASIK vision a secretion a guardian con
can I get my pride in a building salute
all right all right
respect respect now question you got
everybody that's right be a nice person
be inclusive exactly positivity now what
do we need to know to get information on
LASIK okay okay
I need to enter enter for the flu yeah
we got a answer for that free on their
lazy go consultation yes I'm gonna do
that yeah I'll be right back will you
let yes by the river enjoy hi I like the
river the time as though
he surreal
[Music]
change illustrations
just checking it out man so much going
on
the car is lit all food that we got to
see what this gentleman is right
we got to see who this Guardian is who
who is this legendary guardian the
outfit is lit
[Music]
that
right
Liam party conarc okay come on heart in
the building
sorry checking out contour
[Music]
salut
Khan are in a building what's going on
brother Thanks
land party lawyers tell us about land
party lawyers come back so we can
discuss like the legal issues of like
bungee separating from Activision nice
lamp or lawyers respect respect like
Wiseman I've got a partner in crime on
on the East Coast he's a hold law and he
kind of breaks things down similarly to
you guys but this is this dope and I
want to learn more when your partner
comes back
alright I'll loop back on you Oh Barry
ikk Lord Cognito iron law podcast thanks
buddy
absolutely absolutely definitely bro and
there it is
the legends to mention in practice we
found them working still filming I was
just talking to these dudes over here
laying party lawyers you know getting
the legal aspect hold up what's going on
man how's your how's your concert just
wander he's checking it out enjoying all
of the art more than most things I was
actually in the law section chillin with
armed wife you see by four over there
right wife is literally right there
you're like right next door and then
he's right next to Milan
knife gotta say hi to bye
so we gonna catch back up a child
guardian Oh Albatros okay
also known as Guardian headcanons space
that attack boss pick your favor
I've got many names to go by I quit the
band got many using your quick dose I
live in the cave now so these are all
blues links my gun my gun point I can
actually see okay I like it man I like
it hopefully you come back to the tower
over there we need your back okay we'll
get back to the light and don't really
go to the tower very still say the last
City saloon priority salute salute
brother yuria first egg Arika love it
every loan oh he's gonna make the moves
are you gonna make them alone
evil make them moons red
great
blow gnomes in the building salute cool
guy in the building the legendary what's
up bro is join the concert holy shirts
fiber up assure you I even saw some
people buy shirts mom man cuz you're the
coolest
we got a pen is nice well you get that
that's fire I got everything's good
that's fine gentlemen and round again
just the crucible scientists is this
that guy is it the let's go for our
plays in a building with subcircuit
that's an OG iron Lord you already know
we got downloads an ability already know
you enjoy a console game shows here
which is star you didn't know I know he
was here he's on stage helping give away
the belt the big show starts for the
first year they turned out it was like
the [ __ ] if you dude you're back crack
like France said that's the guy to get
you back 20 that's we do that out every
I'd like for people doubt their let's
people
should we think rhymes with people with
people with creeper do you think brother
always a pleasure
always on me is this the legendary
Osiris the legend Wow the costume is
amazing we need you back we need you
back in destiny despite what the DLC
said no this suit is amazing salute the
legend got the show
deeds in a building
was live
that the sidings going on
[Music]
one second for the one I gotta get this
is this a disciple of Osiris yes
that is amazing that is and the shirt
Cyrus the best DLC I don't have anyone
says I'll give early the law is amazing
where's that guy
okay Marcus Marcus
[Applause]
get out of Cyrus I
that's what you sent me today was all
about my bank accounts Donna is he
weren't gonna just order this right then
sure but I want to speak up because I
might want something see if you could do
something special
all right there's another amazing
amazing work of art
thank you very much
[Music]
you
[Music]